- NOW, KIDS, IN HONOR
OF VETERANS DAY,
WE'VE GOT A VERY SPECIAL
GUEST SPEAKER.
A REAL, LIVE WAR HERO:
WOODY JOHNSON.
- HI, KIDS, SHE'S RIGHT.
I AM A WAR HERO.
- MY DAD'S A FIREMAN.
- YOUR DAD IS A PUSSY.
- AW.
- WHILE YOUR FATHERS
WERE ALL SMOKING DOOBIES
AND WASHING OUT
THEIR VAGINAS,
I WAS IN THE SHIT
FIGHTING FOR YOUR FREEDOM...
WHEN I WASN'T GIVING IRAQI
WHORES MY VEINY HUSSEIN-Y.
[laughs]
- CAN YOU SKIP TO THE PART
WHERE YOU GOT YOUR MEDAL?
- I'M GETTING TO THAT,
BITCH.
I WAS IN AN ELITE SPECIAL OPS
UNIT CALLED THE RED SKULLS.
ONE DAY WHEN WE WERE
ON PATROL,
A FELLOW SOLDIER,
PRIVATE JACKUBOWSKI,
GOT WOUNDED.
I SAVED HIS LIFE.
I DRAGGED THAT HALF-DEAD BASTARD
OVER THREE MILES
OF WAR-TORN DESERT.
IT WAS A TRULY BRAVE ACT.
- HOW DID THE SOLDIER
GET HURT?
- WHAT ARE YOU,
THE [bleep] HAGUE?
IT WAS A LONG TIME AGO.
LIKE I CAN REMEMBER
ALL THE DETAILS.
[grunts]
NOW WE ARE BLOOD BROTHERS
FOR LIFE.
WE'LL ALWAYS HAVE
EACH OTHERS' BACKS.
both: RED SKULLS!
RESPECT AND PROTECT!
- OH, THERE YOU GO.
- AAH!